it's like a cross-country run but at a
breakneck pace and where you can
possibly actually break your neck
[Music]
this is star talk sports edition
we're gonna talk about the science of
the weird in this episode
more on that in a moment let me first
introduce my co-host chuck nice chuckie
baby hey what's up neil
oh it's good to have you
actor and comedian we get to say actor
now along with comedian you're you're
acting and stuff you know you tell us
you can get up acting like a comedian
that's what i said oh that's happened
okay acting like a community next time
you need our permission you know if
you're gonna start acting
so also i got my co-host gary o'reilly
gary hey neil
yeah you're stateside but you're you're
fundamentally a brit you sound brit
you talk brit yeah you think walks like
and talks like it must be
but we've got you because of your
professional experience as a as a
footballer a soccer player in england
it's great to have you on you know as
coaches as always
as always so tell me about the sports of
the weird gary because you know i looked
at the notes and said i don't know what
the hell gary cooked up for this show so
take a seat there's a lot in the recipe
here neil um okay in this episode you'll
hear me mention queen elizabeth ii
arnold schwarzenegger sir david
attenborough who is royalty as well the
wu-tang plan squid games and cheese
so you see sports it's a human thing no
other species on this planet
invents a pastime and then organizes
into a championship or a tournament the
ancient greeks well they had the
olympics and every village in town wait
wait wait
wait gary look even humans don't have
that list of objects and people and
phenomena
and then connect them in any way at all
you're telling me you're connecting
those in this episode yes
and you'll see as we go along now it's
it's all about finding out the fastest
and the strongest and you know who can
throw the furthest all of that sort of
thing but
there are
sports that didn't make it onto the
olympic playlist so if i mention a
couple extreme ironing
right oh that is i love that all right
or mountain unicycling
so this this chuck really basically what
i'm saying is
the brits are mainly responsible for all
of the silly weird and wonderful sports
that are out there and we are going to
look with our best friend charles liu at
the science that's going to be buried in
there
charles lew oh my gosh oh
geek in chief hello
charles it's a great pleasure to be here
as always thank you great to see you
back yes this is like your 50th
appearance on the show something like
that yeah clearly we can't do the show
without you so
so you're you're our geek and she friend
and colleague uh the professor of
astronomy and physics at
uh the city university of new york
staten island yep and chuck always good
to have you oh it's such a pleasure
charles it's always good to have you wow
charles it's all that's right i'm in
this episode i'm charles because the
true chuck there is the one true chuck
when it comes to star talk and that
would be chat that is chuck nice
right there
[Laughter]
great to see everybody so
yeah yeah so they're all good and like i
said as our geek in chief however geeky
i think i am you're geeky er so that's
why we have you on here
in the geek spectrum which knows no
bounds you speak so kindly of me sir
so so again what's what's what's the
first sport you've got lined up here all
right so i have to go straight for a
british sport cheese rolling
in gloucestershire thought to date back
600 years and be rooted in pagan rituals
all right um so hear the numbers so pay
attention cooper's heel is 200 yards
long it has a gradient of 50 percent and
it's near vertical in places the
original wheel of cheese
weighed between seven and nine pounds
but it is now fake cheese made of foam
for the safety of the spectators which
is bit sad the cheese has been clocked
at 70 miles an hour and the object of
the race is to get to the bottom of the
hill first and probably still be alive
it has been dubbed the world's most
dangerous foot race charles take it away
oh my god wait just just to be clear
when you say the cheese is going 70
miles an hour it's rolling 70 miles an
hour
yeah
it's a classic this is a classic
freshman physics problem neil remember
all those days you roll a wheel of
cheese without slipping down an incline
of 50 to 200 yards at the bottom what is
its velocity remember those things
right right you have to know what the
what you have to know
how
much did the thing like to roll
that's right there's the
the the the uh which the moment of
inertia i guess they called it yes
the disc of the moment of inertia and
then you have to figure out how much of
the kinetic energy goes in the rotation
and how much of it goes in the
translation down the hill
there's this magical thing called
rolling without slipping which allows
you to make some of these really cool
calculations if you start sliding then
bets are off
but we're assuming that these cheeses
roll right there they're not just like
slip sliding away down there no they're
they're bouncing absolutely
what about when they're level the ground
i would say bounding
down
get along little cheesies okay we're
moving along here's here's your tape
it's 200 yards long right
which is 600 feet and a 50 grade roughly
that means what's the square root of 2
by 0.7 is the height it's 50 grade 45
degree angle correct is that right it is
yeah yeah okay so square root of two out
of them so of 600 feet right so that's
about 400 feet or thereabouts now uh if
you remember your physics from uh like i
said one half a t squared how long it
takes to fall 400 feet
the answer is about four seconds
okay so uh the acceleration of gravity
going straight down
about four seconds at each second you go
32 feet per second uh faster than you
did before or about 22 miles an hour
faster which means that if you've just
fell straight down from the top 200
yards all the way vertically like off a
cliff you know wiley coyote kind of
falling when you hit the bottom you'd be
going around 80 to 90 miles an hour
okay but you're rolling okay so some of
it is going into your rolling some of it
is going away and some of the times
you're bounding then you're not
constrained by gravity at all so 70
miles an hour
actually makes sense you could actually
get to that speed now a human being
couldn't do that because we don't roll
without slipping when we roll we slip
badly right that's how we roll
yeah score one for chuck good job man
that was a good one i wish i thought of
that one
that's how i roll i don't know
now uh a person running right using bolt
on a flat
field will run 200 yards at a speed of
about 20 to 25 miles per hour
and so yeah you get that gravity assist
a little bit then it's a matter of
trying to figure out whether you can
plant your foot and rotate your speed
fast enough kind of like uh the flash or
or you know
the road run or something right yeah
meet me
you have to make sure that your feet are
synced with how fast you're falling
combined with how fast you can turn so
you could probably wait you said
something very important there charles
what you're saying is
as you're running you i mean this is so
obvious that to say it it's like what is
that what we actually do what you're
saying is when i leap
i have to make sure that when i come in
contact with the ground again
it's the bottom of my foot that's doing
it not my knee or my elbow or my head
that's right
right okay so so there it is that's why
you have the ambulances waiting at the
bottom of the hill for this one right
here for sure
so so the answer is you know you have to
time your motion of your feet to
compensate not just for your regular
running but when you're falling and then
you've got to know where your foot is
going to land and so that's another
physics problem fortunately human beings
are great at physics not necessarily
great at writing down answers on a on a
piece of paper but great is sort of
calculating where our foot needs to be
at any given time to reach the ground
just as we are reaching the ground i
mean physiologically we're good at that
calculation that's right
we're doing our brains just do it for us
if you actually watch people chasing a
wheel of cheese down cooper's hill
they are not smoothly running they are
flipping slipping sliding
banging into each other and things
because it's
this is a natural hill so it's got all
sorts of divots and bumps and lumps in
it so uh
it's just hilarious to watch wait so
gary i thought this was a race between
cheese wheels because then if that's
what it is we could pre-load the wheel
using some physics and you could win
that every time if you knew physics 101.
yeah
this is a 600 year old
sport they weren't the richest back then
so they could only afford the one wheel
of cheese and that is way before anybody
knew physics or how to win this right
like so what would you do to your wheel
if you
oh well you you want it to have the most
amount of its kinetic energy going down
the hill in the least amount of it's
spinning right okay yeah which would
mean wouldn't you want to like cool
squish the cheese to a more like a
bowling ball rather than a wheel into
the middle right okay uh-huh bowling
ball filled with cheese there you go
wait yeah
what what yeah what's the moment of
inertia of a sphere again it's smaller
let me give you my equation here's what
you do with the cheese oh chuck's got an
equation
you eat it
just eat it yeah screw this game guys
i'm hungry
but the cheese is like 70 pounds dude
okay for all okay so
here's what i want
gary can you eat a wheel of cheese after
you roll it down a hill
um is it still edible is my point
yes because okay well in that case you
just gotta wrap it really carefully oh
yeah they do they they put a wooden sort
of
case around it i was wondering it's
probably not brie
now you mentioned it
it will be double gloucester which is a
harder cheese oh good double blaster not
likely to end up splattering everything
is this just what we would call cheddar
and you'll call it double glue no no no
gosh no
cheddar double gloucester red
leicestershire it's all it's all bonkers
but it's not it sounds like firm cheese
okay got it yeah it is
i had it wrong i'm not racing cheese
wheels erasing people down the hill
following a cheese wheel
and it's not a straight line and it's
not a thing and and and chuck getting
back to your usain bolt reference yeah
usain bolt might not win that race
because it's not a straight path correct
it's like a cross-country run but at a
breakneck pace and where you can
possibly actually break your neck
that's about right i gotta tell ya
when you explain it that way i wanna
watch this sport
damn okay
all right so and this has been going on
for how long
about 600 years oh wow oh
yeah now if they use the same wheel of
cheese that's one hard cheese has lasted
for 600 years that's like not double
gloucester that's like uh quintuple
gloucester by then no that's that's not
going to be happening
definitely evidence that there was no
cable television built
no hbo for sure exactly
all right so gary what's what next sport
what in this crazy-ass sport you have
from europe okay we're moving out of
britain but not too far we're going to
norway okay
there is such a thing as the world
belly flop championships all right
okay well okay i don't have time wait we
have to put that in the next segment
okay
don't even start that until we have a
fresh segment to put that in this is
star talk sports edition weird sports
from throughout the world
uh brought to you by gary i got nothing
to do with this one oh it's on me
this is all gary all right we'll be back
in a moment
we're back star talk sports edition
uh gary o'reilly has called from
throughout the world
specifically his part of the world crazy
ass sports that uh
gary i think you you made this episode
take place
so that one day we will look at curling
and say hey that's a good sport yeah i
think you're trying to reset or you've
got to recalibrate
anybody ever looked at the sport curling
we got a geek in chief charles lew uh
he's always good to to take us to places
we we we didn't even think of going and
of course chuck knight so keep it so
keep it going gary all right so
the world championships of belly
flopping is a thing
but it's really taken on uh a massive
interest in norway where it's known as
dodging
which translates apparently into death
diving
right now now now this sounds weird it
was invented in 1972 by erling bruno
hovden
you start on a 10 to 14 meter diving
tower which translates just to be clear
1972 was before lead was banned in
drinking water
that's one year before the laws went
into effect at least in the united
states of banning lead and let it gas
but could be anecdotal but could be a
connection i'm just saying
so you're diving off of a tower into a
swimming pool at 32 to 45 46 feet high
there's classic belly flop arms out
stretched legs out stretch you just hit
the surface of the water then there's
freestyle where in mid-air you have
stunts and then just as they're about to
impact you just curl up in a ball and
cannonball through there so because it's
not a belly flap
no but there's classic belly flop
so there's two different events you can
enter the classic or go for the
freestyle oh so you can go oh oh so far
oh okay so the freestyle is it
it's not how much splash you don't make
it's how much splash you do make and
it's no it's in the the mid-air stunts
you have to perform a mid-air stunt and
hold it for as long as you possibly can
this a dodds is is is the dive there is
an international dodds federation
although the delightful people of the
norwegian swimming federation do not
recognize it
um this the world championships
will attract something like 3 000 paying
spectators
so um it's it's quite a thing so charles
if yes if i take a running jump as say
like a man of
170 pounds or something like that off
okay
tower some 30 40 feet high okay what
sort of force am i going to hit the
surface of the water
that's a good question but you have to
be a little bit careful about this
because it's not so much the force that
matters right the amount of force you're
experiencing from gravity uh is a
constant amount right your mass
times the acceleration of gravity 9.8
meters per second rather
it's the momentum you have when you
reach the water
and how much time it takes for you to
slow down
right and then that leaves you with the
thing called impulse so the amount of
force you experience is if you have a
whole bunch of momentum
and you're falling and in a very short
time or a very long time you you reduce
that momentum to zero
right so if you that's why for example
when you're on the side of the road you
have these crash pads or near the toll
booths or something like that the slower
the longer it takes for you to sl stop
the less force you will experience at
any given time
so it's it's a combination that's why
high jumpers have big pillows on the
other side exactly you want to slow down
their fall not so much to sort of stop
it so so it's not just the amount of
force which would be the mass of the
individual uh well 170 pounds is what
about 80 kilograms or so 75. i got to
say this just so that chuck doesn't have
to say it so there'd be another olympics
where you have the pole vault and they
land on cement that's a different sport
norwegians invent that too
[Laughter]
they they are tough people
i i thought the ski jump was already bad
enough i don't know if they invented
them but but imagine going down a hill
in your skis through the air like 300
feet and then landing that's really
amazing those guys are very impressive
so yeah you bottom line is uh if you're
belly flopping right you are hitting not
only uh quickly you're stopping really
fast but you also have a large surface
area
on which that you're hitting so every
single spot on your skin gets smacked
those good divers well i don't say good
those
professional divers or olympic divers
they're always trying to be as vertical
as possible right right little splashes
that's right so that when you hit you
have the smallest surface area you slice
through and you don't actually feel a
lot of pain then you let the water stop
you the underwater cameras they go down
10 feet or something that's right so
over that 10 feet they're slowing down
that's right right and that makes it
really nice now now at what point does
the water itself
uh offer enough resistance to just break
you in half or like bust your bones up
or i mean there's got to be a point
where that water becomes as hard as
cement
well it's the golden gate bridge
people don't survive jumping off that
bridge right right it's a it's a um
surface
effect as it turns out basically um but
the way materials work because you're
going from an uh low density into high
density even if that uh water is liquid
when you hit you can have a
substantially strong amount of impulse
that gets hit to you at that time and
and exactly when you're jumping from a
high distance into water if you hit uh
even from your platform there at 30 or
uh 30 feet or 40 feet gary
you can break bones you can
snap joints if you're not careful so
those belly floppers aren't just playing
around they're probably being very very
careful that they hit with the soft part
of their torsos so they don't actually
hit with their head and their chin going
up against their
the rest of their body and thus snapping
something like a spine i mean the record
the record is over a hundred feet that's
crazy one of these deaths with the
record for someone who lived
yeah i'm guessing i mean that's not the
classic belly flop right oh i hope no
i'm sure that's curling into it
yeah the curling into a cannonball at
the last moment you can probably hit
with your you know buttocks or something
like that and you're much less likely to
break something that's irreparable right
but but you can't sit down for at least
a week
[Laughter]
that water becomes your therapy space as
well as your uh
landing space
yeah so it is interesting so in the
cannonball if you hit butt first
um
so charles is a is is a fat butt or a
narrow butt better
for a cannonball land oh
well that oh well there are two actors
at work there right because when you're
talking about i mean the left butt cheek
right left and the right yeah let's see
exactly
if you're hitting trying to minimize
your your cross-sectional area hitting
the water then you want that narrow
turret right on the other hand the
turrets has substantial padding and that
will slow down
your
time of deceleration right the amount of
time it takes for you to reduce your
speed just like a bumper on a car would
so you may want more bumper to slow you
down and thus you may not want to hit
directly as tail on as possible but just
a little bit off to the side so you get
that nice fatty cushion but doesn't that
dissipate the energy better yeah i'd
have to do the calculations i think that
would be a lot of fun to do okay so but
so so gary this is now 50 a 50 year old
sport is it does it make money is it
if there's 3 000 spectators turning up
for the world championships i'm guessing
they make money because they'll be all
the sort of merchandising they'll be
awesome and it appears on tv
so
they're selling the tv rights they're
selling out spectators in stadiums in
norway so um yeah the world champions
are belly flopping it's on
it's out there making money
norway television must really suck
if this is if that's a if that's a prime
time spirit right if this is a prime
time sport
okay chuck let's just get this fair it
the winters in northern norway are long
and dark
and in the summers the sun up up in
places like narvik the sun will not set
during summer so there's a lot of
difference up there so summer's the
opposite of the winters the days are
long and it never gets dark
yep yeah because i think in the winter
the nights are long and it never gets
light
right so that all switches out so so
charles
any calculation fast calculation in your
head about whether a 300 pound fat
person relative to a 130 pound skinny
person would do better in this kind of
event oh gee calculate real quick
because we think you know with a lot of
fat that's yeah it's it protects your
inner organs right yep
if in the classic
in the classic where you're actually
landing on your belly you do want more
subcutaneous belly stuff to slow you
down when you land you definitely want
in the classic belly flop as long as you
have good technique and you're landing
on your belly properly right without
like bending your spine too much that
you wind up snapping it or something
then you probably want to be a larger
and have more fat now so that would take
the energy of contact and dissipate it
into your fat without breaking your ribs
for example that's right that's exactly
what you would want on the other hand if
you were that cannonball thing you do
your tricks in the air then you curl
into a ball and drop in i think being
thin would be better because then your
profile going in will be smaller right
and if you if you're heavy
going in into the cannonball
it'd be like in in in all of the the
water parks with the with the fish with
the you know the porpoise shows there's
a splash zone yes
that's right first temperatures
yeah you would you would wind up uh
producing quite a splash no question
about it hey so gary anything else you
want to add to this before we go on to
the next uh
i think we've
[Laughter]
[Music]
allowed me to say allow me to just
shout out to the norwegians okay
at this moment
the norwegians
they have this fascinating sport which
is still intriguing to all of us on this
panel but they also have the world
record for the 400 meter hurdle
and they have the highest ranking chess
player there ever was
wow
okay
and this count this is a country of how
many people eight
eight eight people yeah
right you know a few million like
somewhere between like a five million
people maybe yeah absolutely yeah as
many as in a metropolitan area over of a
city in america so that's you know
they're doing something right oh yeah
you got you know give them their belly
flop if the rest of this is going down
the way it is yeah hooray for norway i
say yeah there you go all right all
right so so uh gary what what sport is
up next face slapping oh no oh oh oh oh
all right all right yeah there it is
again okay we're going to take a break
and we'll come back
we'll come back
and talk about face slapping as a sport
on star talk sports edition when we
return
we're back star talks sports edition
odd unusual sports
all of which gary invented
yeah
with my norwegian chums
yeah just yeah we talked about cheese
rolling yep we talked about belly
flapping belly flopping and what's the
next topic here gary
as i said before the break um face
slapping
i do not have
an origin
as national identity for this thing it's
been featured in squid games the netflix
show oh
get out yeah so here we go they love it
in russia
there's one of their slap kings that's
the official term is vasily chamos this
guy or
affectionately known as dumpling who
weighs in at 370 pounds oh my god it's
open to both men and women but they
don't hit you know you say you know
women women
the rules are simple you get five slaps
each that's if you get that far
and if you evade a slap you get a foul
two fouls and you're out you can only
use the upper part of your palm and
cannot touch the jaw temple or ear
what's left on the face to slap the
cheek the cheek right here yeah yeah
connect it to the jaw
but you don't hit the jaw you can only
hit the cheek yeah
okay okay
yeah that makes sense because you don't
break the jaw you're right charles you
sound like you helped write the rules
how you i thought you were as new to
this as the rest of us on this on this
call well
all right go on go on gary what else so
we've got someone who's 370 pounds
his arms are probably like my legs and
he's going to slap me in the face and
i'm standing there and letting him do it
ouch
what determines who wins
oh if you just say i've had enough
you you have to stand your ground
and be slapped
you only get five you only get five
shots didn't you just say yeah so so
anyone can handle five shots you think
not not with not with someone has meat
hands coming at you right 370 pounds
because you've got you've got a straight
arm lever
you've got
a gigantic hand that's coming at you i
can't imagine what sort of speed
but i don't like the idea of that here's
how this uh game works for me i get to
go first and then i quit
[Music]
gonna be someone who is so
determined not to quit they'll stick it
out
unless they get knocked out yeah these
are these are crazy people right these
are people who see the world at the
weird what country what country leads
this
i don't think there is a leader although
it is popular in russia apparently
man so is this a spectator sport
yes they have championships and
although the prize money isn't ex
enormous
you get to walk out there with about a
thousand dollars or something like that
and they'll have championships based
around places and obviously there's
weight categories i would imagine you
know
the 370 pound giant
pitching up against the 100 pound wheat
right you don't want anybody slapped
into orbit
that's exactly it yeah are you are you
allowed to enter other people
as as attackers or as targets well yes
targets yeah like i'll tell you what
i'll tell you what gary um a thousand
bucks or so can certainly buy you a lot
of ice packs right so it's probably yeah
it's just exactly the right amount of
ice packs that's right that's right but
i would not necessarily discount a thin
person or a lightweight person doing
poorly compared to a heavyweight person
in this kind of competition why
well think about it it's on speed right
the arm speed is what matters more than
anything else the kinetic energy is one
half m v squared right v the velocity it
increases much faster than the mask
which is all increases linearly right so
if you can be really fast then you're
good not to mention let's say if you are
thin you might be more limber in your
joints
and thus when you get struck you might
be able to uh absorb it a little bit
better by allowing your face and your
neck to destroy
yeah just to change it's again
increasing the amount of time your body
has to absorb the force and therefore
experience less force because as we
talked about earlier and just to
emphasize the point charles made the
most lethal bullets fired out of a rifle
are not the fattest heaviest bullets
they're very small that you know the m16
rifle high velocity
high muzzle velocity is it like a
practice a 22 caliber somewhere around
0.223 yeah so basically a 22 caliber
bullet
so they they said let's give up some
mass but put it all in the velocity and
that's what makes it so lethal so very
good point charles so charles um what if
you have less nerve endings in your
cheek i mean
how many nerve endings in the human
cheek can't answer please oh um millions
yeah but uh yes you if you were somehow
uh genetically uh predisposed that you
had fewer uh cheek nerve cells uh then
you might tolerate the pain a little bit
more right but i'm thinking more along
the lines of the damage that it would do
to your face
right how much uh how many blood vessels
would break the millions of capillaries
that are in your cheek muscles of those
kinds of things and so in that sense you
can imagine a very
not heavyweight person but with a lot of
cheek fat right um
and that that would make you a very
strong candidate in this kind of contest
uh so the similar thing to the belly
flopping so the the dissipation
interesting right right interesting
gary you got one more sport i think is
that right uh yeah let's
let's do another uh one of the finest
sports ever created by the brits
shin kicking
shin kick
is that the finns the finns do that
there is a wife carrying a competition
and
yeah it's over an obstacle course
and they
so that this is before they're married
or after they're married in preparation
for the threshold you don't actually
have to carry your own wife or have a
wife you have to have a
young woman or a woman over the age of
17 who
you carry over i think there's two
they would dry hurdles
over that age anyway and that wouldn't
have to be a rule in the sport but go on
that's a rule the rule is and wife
carrying the the woman must be over 17
years of age wow you you throw over your
shoulders kind of there's different
there's different styles like a sack of
potatoes okay well
no i'm not referring to young ladies as
a potatoes there's the piggy bank like a
mink stall
yeah and there's the fireman's carry
then there's a thing called estonia
style what's that oh okay so
basically
the woman is over your shoulders and her
legs come over
over the front of you and you hold on to
those and that i suppose charles is
it's kind of like a counterbalance a
lever yes and allows you to
okay i thought this was a family show
let me tell you what you just described
so how did this begin
the wife carrying saying um no no no
just just go to the shin kicking go
ahead all right so shin kicking is
another british thing in it's in the
same part of the world as the cheese
rolling so obviously they definitely
don't have cable tv
um it goes back about 400 years to a
thing called the cotswold olympics and
that's olympic spelt with a k
um
you it it should be on the surface the
stupidest sport anyone could ever ever
have invented but there's something
going on with it
um it takes place in the beautiful area
of the cotswolds
uh they have banned steel toe cats wait
wait is that a person place or thing the
cocktail place the cotswold it's an area
of uh of britain just to the south west
thank you for forgiveness it's chocolate
american geographic ignorance i think
there's a cheese named cotswold isn't it
yes there probably will be we'd like to
choose
it does have a deeper meaning
and it's strange but if i explain it
maybe then you'll have a better
understanding
shin kicking is absurd right but not
without this meaning it's about standing
your ground it's about stubbornly
resisting the assaults that come your
way and giving back as good as you get
um
yeah it's
okay so it's about revenge okay there's
rooms
you stand there stand your ground you
kick somebody in the shins yeah
and then how much time do you get how do
they get to recover because i've never
been kicked in the shins i've never
bumped my shin on a coffee table i've
never even scraped my shin without
immediately pulling it up to my chest
and writhing in pain or
so how much time do you get to recover
it's it's an ongoing bout
so
each here we go this is the quaint
british tradition each person has to
wait there's two people in a ring to
begin with right a circular ring and
there's a judge outside
and they have both have to wear white
coats
they have to hold on to the collar of
each of their opponent
and if they get them on the ground they
win and they're off three count them one
two three rounds and you can only kick
between the knee and the foot
okay so it's like wrestling
with kicking yes you're you're holding
the person like though i forget the
whole that you when you see those guys
wrestling they start off with their hand
on their neck
and then you and then you get to kick
the guy and if if somebody goes down
that's then they win they you you ground
your opponent you get a point
and uh you get as many whoever gets the
most points after three rounds wins or
if someone says you know what i've had
enough my shin's really hurt now i'm
going home
it still sounds like gary that people
they need more streaming tv services
a lot of bored people and
the twisted mind that came up with this
i i don't quite know but it's a thing
shin kicking i hope they're allowed to
wear shin guards
you know what they do they okay so they
wear trousers
okay and they stuff
hay
down the legs of their trousers
to give them some protection but really
so it's not the least bit uncomfortable
either
tradition of stuffing your pants yes i
understand
i would have stuffed a metal plate
down my pants
this is 400 years old the excess of
ready-made metal shin guards
that blacksmith would have been my
friend i'm with neil on this one hay on
top
metal metal against the skin i mean
there are so many more
uh weird sports there's a sport called
goanna pulling okay it's that the the
aussies came up with that
um then you've got it
you mean like australians not the
aussies like ozzie and harriet right the
australians the down unders um then
you've got chess boxing
okay which has become yes you heard me
no t in there chuck chess boxing
so you have
a round of chess you they play blitz
chess right so you have a round of chess
and then they go and have a three-minute
boxing
round come back
round of chess three minutes and they
alternate so you win by checkmate or
knockout
um
really
you have to have uh i think it's called
an elo isn't it the chess sort of
gradient system you have to have 1600
and above
it's pretty good as a chess
and have been at least
have 50 amateur bouts as a boxer
to compete professionally
so this guarantees
that
you will
lose your cognitive
exactly
so this there'd be good data there find
out what happens to your chest rating
every time you get knocked out and then
this is this is important concussion uh
data i mean the thing is the
science has taken an interest in chest
boxing
because it's
the ability to flip-flop out of a
physical
strenuous
demand like a
round of boxing and then sit down and be
calm
yeah wow
yeah okay i know i don't i don't know
any
real life situations where you might
have to do that
i think it's it's it's how the brain
hey man
this guy's just moving the hell out of
me
but right now i got to do some calculus
that's what happened to me all the time
in high school chuck i don't know what's
wrong oh
nice well played sir well played says
the geek in chief so guys we got to land
that plane so
uh gary there's probably a longer list
than we would even oh gosh
okay conquers which well we're out of
time gary no no i've got to drop some
names here concourse just in case the
ones that we've already discussed are
not weird enough okay a favorite of
queen elizabeth ii and sir david
attenborough so i got those two names in
and arnold schwarzenegger is a big fan
of face slapping
okay
and the wu-tang clang have a song about
chess boxing
there you go all connected
well by the way we've had the gizza on
star talk
many years ago in the early seasons
so uh we get around on this on this show
so wait wait so what's the favorite
sport of queen elizabeth
she was a big fan of conker's
which is a horse chestnut
you know those things in the swing
and you drill
you put a string through and then you
try and smash your opponent's conquer
with it
conquers
another conqueror
what's a conquer
it's a horse chestnut yes no oh what do
you mean you won't have to smash their
conkers with your conkers yes
oh
uh interesting
again you had me at home you had my
horse chestnut
i would have more fun swinging
cantaloupes at one another and having
them smash
that's the gallagher version
good one next point to everyone who uh
chuck who who gallagher is yeah you
gotta look up gallagher there's no
you're looking at him yeah
if you don't know what who gallagher is
kids just go to go to go to youtube
yeah look up annie gallagher clip it'll
be exactly what you've got to say right
my favorite line from gallagher and then
we gotta call it quits
he was the one that came up with which
was later than repeated by other
comedians i think he said
if
pro
is the opposite of kong
then progress is the opposite of
congress
oh
yeah god that saying just keeps getting
better with you that came out of him
yeah yeah yeah all right guys uh gary we
got to do this again because apparently
we did not exhaust your list no uh this
has been star talk
the weird sports edition and uh
charles always good to have you man
pleasure all right guys uh that's has
been star talk sports edition neil
degrasse tyson here keep looking
[Music]